now a discussion on international law
and the recent arrest of former chilean
president agusto pinochet
this 75-minute event was hosted by
american university's washington college
of law
good evening i'd like to thank you all
for attending on behalf of the american
university washington college of law
hispanic law students association i
would like to welcome you
and
wish you bienvenidos to our panel
discussion
entitled throwing down the gauntlet the
arrest of pinochet and the question of
international law my name is aj stone
i'm a second year law student here at
wcl i'm the publications chairperson for
the hispanic law students association
and i'll serve as moderator this evening
before we begin i'd like to extend
halsey's enormous appreciation to a few
people without whom this program would
not be possible
many thanks to lisa tronyar in the
dean's office and kathy edemaid in media
relations i would also like to thank the
executive board of halsa elianor samosa
watana tucker and miguel cordano our
vice president who is unable to be here
tonight
and also also wishes to thank uh halsa
members leticia vazquez carlos ferdinand
and esteban elias for their invaluable
help
before we get started what i'd like to
go ahead and do is give you a brief
history
of the
situation as it's developed starting
back in 1973.
on september 11 1973 the armed forces of
chile under the direction of then of
their commander in chief augusto
pinochet overthrew the democratically
elected socialist government of salvador
allende
pinochet installed himself as head of
the government dissolving the
legislature
under pinochet's rule it is alleged that
at least three thousand chileans and
other foreign nationals
were executed or otherwise listed as
disappeared
in 1976 a car bomb exploded on sheridan
circle here in washington d.c down on
massachusetts avenue killing allende's
former foreign minister
ortando orlando letelier and his
american secretary ronnie moffatt
agents of the chilean secret police were
implicated in the bombing as a way of
silencing latelier's vehement criticism
of the pinochet regime
in 1978 a general amnesty law was passed
in chile granting immunity to all
members of the chilean armed forces who
may have committed human rights
violations in chile between 1973 and
1978.
in 1989 a plebiscite was held to
determine whether the chilean people
wished for general pinochet to continue
as head of the government or whether
chile should hold free elections
the plebiscite was returned in favor of
open democratic elections and in 1990
the elected government of patricio alwyn
took office
general pinochet remained as
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
to be followed by a lifetime tenure as
senator for life in the chilean
legislature this is a position which he
assumed in
march of 1998 this year
last week general pinochet entered a
private london hospital for spinal
surgery
at the request of spanish magistrate
balthazar garzon british authorities
placed general pinochet under house
arrest as he recuperated
spanish authorities seek to extradite
general pinochet to stand trial for
human rights violations
more recently switzerland indicated that
it too was interested in seeking charges
against general pinochet
we are very fortunate to have a
very well-rounded panel with us tonight
a very experienced panel um i'll start
off with a man that you all know very
well our dean claudio grossman
dean grossman is a graduate of the
university at the chile is a law school
in santiago chile
and also the university of amsterdam in
the netherlands where he received his
doctor of science of the law
he is a member of the inter-american
commission on human rights the
organization of american states
dean grossman has also litigated before
the inter-american court on human rights
of the organization of american states
in fact he is probably litigated before
the organization or the
inter-american commission on human
rights more than any other litigator
we also have with us professor michael
tiger professor of law here at wcl
professor tiger is an expert in criminal
justice and was lead counsel for terry
nichols
he is he remains the attorney for both
the families of orlando lately and
ronnie moffett who i as i indicated were
killed by car bomb here in washington dc
professor richard wilson is joining us
he's a professor of law and director of
the international human rights law
clinic
here at the washington college of law he
serves as legal advisor to the republic
of colombia in washington on issues of
colombian detainees in the united states
he was a fulbright scholar in the
republic of colombia in 1986 director of
the law school summer study program in
chile in 1995 and 96 has been a visiting
lecturer in tokyo japan
and finally
joining us professor diane orentlicker
professor arne linker received her jd
from columbia university
she is director of wcl's war crimes
research office
and she is a member of the advisory
council lawyers committee for human
rights and of the advisory council for
the international human rights law group
and of the law group's women in the law
project she's been a human rights
investigator in argentina chile cuba the
former czechoslovakia el salvador
ethiopia honduras indonesia
israeli-occupied territories nicaragua
the philippines and
the thai cambodia border turkey and the
former yugoslavia
passport must be very well stamped
to start off with
i would
like to throw out just a question that
any panelists can answer any order you
want to
just to set some initial parameters
what is the one thing about this
incident
that speaks to you on a individual or
professional level
we'll start off with dean grossman
well let me first thank you for the
invitation to this panel the
the students in this school always find
very important to address the key issues
of our time and
very proud to be in this institution and
see the initiatives that our student
body takes in spite of
the fact that they are very busy with
the normal
travail of being a law student so
congratulations to you and to a hispanic
law student association
on a personal level there are different
issues here involved one thing
that you see in the hemisphere and not
only
this
expectation of justice that continues to
be
very valid in terms of what the humans
brings and
want to to achieve and and and i think
that that is a key issue involved here
many
thought that
there wouldn't be any development in
issues involving
pinocchio and the fact that this
detention that took place has
reopened the possibilities for many to
get justice and that's a key issue and
then to finalize this there are another
related issues here involved and it's a
very serious problems in the region
region which is the issue of impunity
they
we are not guaranteed in the region as a
whole that nobody is above the law and
then i think that this
this
detention touches on very widely and
broadly felt aspirations
of many who want to live in a world
where justice is dead
thank you
um
i thought that was a wonderful question
to start with because
i've been very struck in the last week
by how much this event really has
touched people in a very personal way
for me it's it's been significant for a
number of reasons not the least of which
is
that i'm surrounded literally on this
panel and by other colleagues here by
people who've devoted the last 25 years
or so to trying to seek some measure of
justice for
the thousands of victims of pinochet's
government and it seemed like a real
sisyphean task a real labor of devotion
to principles that had to be pursued
even though they seemed
wildly unrealistic and what was quite
extraordinary about what happened a week
and a half ago is that something that
seemed
really beyond reach
seemed actually possible
it was no longer fantastic to imagine
that the man who more than anyone else
embodied impunity for atrocious crimes
could actually be called to account the
other extraordinary aspect of it i
thought was the role of private
individuals in making this all happen i
suspect my colleague rick wilson will
say more about this so i'll say very
little but
the
the investigations in spain were
initiated by private parties and
clearly would not have gone as far as
they
had have gone but for the commitment of
some individuals not private parties but
investigating magistrates and to me this
was a wonderful moment for the human
rights movement because while those
efforts built on decades of
activism by people around the world
the moment was crystallized by
individuals who sort of believed that
these principles actually should mean
something in their life and took action
to make it happen so i thought it was
quite a wonderful moment for the human
rights movement
well for these events the last weeks
bring into focus uh
something that i've been working on for
a while my partner
law partner for many years sam buffon is
sitting over there and
i think back to september of 1976 in the
wake of the assassination of orlando
latillier and ronnie moffat here in
washington d.c and the meetings that we
had with
succession of attorneys general in an
effort to see that there was some action
there and then the civil suit that
resulted in a judgment against the
republic of chile
and i remember sitting in judge joyce
hensgreen's court
and we asked a witness
how could it be
that the order could be given to carry
out an assassination
on the streets of washington d.c
and the witness saying well surely
no one other than general penichet could
have authorized that
and their remark
went on and it went into the record
and now here we are
and what's hopeful for me about these
events is that we are seeing a replay
this is not the first time
that someone
who is 80 years old
is about to be summoned or may be
summoned to the bar of justice to answer
for
crimes against humanity and that after a
movement an international movement sam
and i addressed audiences in many parts
of the world
the successful prosecution of paul
touvier
who was a an official of the vichy
government in france who caused the
execution of seven jews one morning at
ryu le pop
who then sought to the looting of their
stores
people thought that it would be
impossible that duvier could ever be
brought to justice duvier de gaulle said
dusboldon le po
12 bullets in his hide if they could
find him
he had been amnestied
the people thought maybe the statute of
limitations had run and yet
organizations of private persons sorted
the incorporation into french penal law
of the provision of the london accord on
crimes against humanity he an
investigating magistrate was diligent
the police went out eventually they
found him hiding in a monastery they
brought him to trial and they convicted
him
uh reinforcing the principle that these
principles of international law
can be brought to life in the country in
countries and forums that are willing to
give them life and
it requires the movements of the kind
that we've seen that are reflected by
the attendance here today
and that's what makes me hopeful that
sam befone and i and these other lawyers
are right to stand anywhere near these
events
is simply the product of people having
suffered and being willing to raise
their voices to see that justice is done
that's
i mean it's a long talk but
i'm very hopeful today
i think
what strikes me most personally is
how far
these cases have come and from what
point they started
i had the great good fortune and pure
luck to be on a panel
uh invited to speak in santiago chile in
december of
1996
almost two years ago with a couple of
young spanish lawyers who began to talk
very enthusiastically about
a case they had filed some six months
earlier
in the spanish domestic courts against
the military leadership of both
argentina
and chile
and over breakfast one morning we talked
i think for almost three hours about the
excitement they felt about how
they didn't know exactly where the case
was going to go and in fact some
not some lawyers had told some of the
non-lawyers who were involved on behalf
of the victims that this was
maybe not such a good idea maybe it was
a a a waste of time because after all
you can't try someone in spain without
them being present there's no such thing
as a trial in absentia
we
continue to talk and later that semester
i traveled to madrid and
met with them again and came back with a
handful of requests from those lawyers
which i passed on to students in the
international human rights law clinic
and that began our two-year involvement
providing those lawyers with
legal research primarily on issues of
international criminal law
international human rights law
international humanitarian law
and some
comparative law aspects of
the
way in which spanish law worked in
conjunction with the law of
chile and argentina we also worked with
some very dedicated
ngos on the ground in argentina and
chile
who had made it their business to keep
the flag flying for victims after all
this time
i'm proud to say that we contributed to
their understanding of international law
and i was delighted to see that in the
arrest
warrants issued by judge garcon
last week there were citations to legal
authority which we had provided two
years ago
in our initial memorandum of law
to them
it felt to me as though we had played a
small role i really uh we we had eight
students involved in the first spring we
were involved in this case and they
spent i think we almost camped in the
in the student area in the clinic
downstairs for a couple of weeks to
prepare our first memorandum
in the second year we had six students
and this year i had two
the case had
begun to
move along it there were the questions
were not so urgent and then this case
exploded
into the news
seen
from
a distance seen over this period of time
i think what is not often noticed is
that i would receive a a stack of
newspaper clippings from the press in
spain
in argentina and chile
each month and that stack was about that
thick
each month
for those countries
this is front page news and has been
since the time the initial complaints
were filed
it becomes front page news in the united
states and in the rest of the world
only when someone as notorious as
augusto pinochet is arrested
but
now over the time of this meticulous
investigation undertaken by the two
judges in these two cases
there are
two national leaders
one of whom is sitting in a jail in
argentina awaiting trial for the sale
and kidnapping of children
another military leader who is under
arrest and now awaiting trial
for his role in the argentine
military activities and for his own
involvement in his confession
to having
carried drugged victims in a helicopter
over the open ocean and having dropped
them still alive
into the ocean
there are
36 other military leaders under
indictment unable to leave their
countries without facing the risk of
arrest by interpol
the
amount of energy amount of of
momentum that these cases has generated
for
victims as well has been incredibly
powerful there now i read over the
weekend that new suits have been filed
not only in england
but in switzerland
in new zealand and there were already
cases pending in italy france sweden
germany honduras and ecuador and let me
pick up from there um direct this
question to uh
dean grossman and professor wilson dean
grossman if you could comment on the
procedural issues that have arisen and
what significance if any of issues like
diplomatic immunity and charges of
genocide within the international human
rights community
all right um thank you well
you know pinocchio has been accused of
many crimes but
she has never been accused before of
being a diplomat as a matter of fact
yeah
and probably in that church he would be
innocent
there there are two conventions that i
think should be analyzed here the first
one is the convention and diplomatic
relations of 1961
and the other one is a convention of
new york of
1968 on special diplomatic missions
both conventions require special
accreditation accreditation as a matter
of fact by the states by the state
and much has been amazed of the fact
that
young pinocchio was trialing on a
diplomatic passport and there was a
recent diplomatic passport that from an
international perspective it doesn't
have much significance
accreditation is required here so i
don't see much in in the
in the issue of a diploma of diplomatic
immunity now
other issues
involving procedural issues probably are
issues
concerning extraterritorial application
of pain and loss
extra
that is a
a matter
that
probably formed the basis of
jurisdiction in international law but we
have seen
since the second world war onwards the
development in this matter concerning
crimes against humanity
crimes against peace and crimes of war
and piercing that the
notion of territorial jurisdiction that
you have to do something in the country
where it happened that however very
serious issues involving here
concerning this matter would be better
of course to have an international
criminal tribunal an international
period of tribunal because there are all
type of issues
that could arise involving free or lost
litigation and abuse of this type of
enforcement through domestic judiciary
but we should see
this in a positive light in other words
the this type of
action should raise awareness about the
need of of creating international
jurisdiction where living in a global
world in economics the environment and
and we need to globalize further our
commitment to
to criminal justice also who has a
global connotation and reflects a core
of value to which we all here otherwise
we run the risk of
of very serious problems in in terms of
this national education so these are a
couple of issues there is finally but
an issue involving humanitarian action
and probably we can discuss that a
little bit later okay
i think uh
i would i would
also
suggest that the
the most crucial issues here have to do
with the
questions about the application of
international criminal law but i think
one of the most confusing things
in the press and with regard to public
and understanding of this case
particularly here in the united states
is
the role of private prosecutors in
initiating a criminal case such as this
spanish law
as does the civil law in many of the
european countries permits
private individuals to take a criminal
case to court and pursue that case as
private prosecutors throughout at least
the instruction stage that is the
investigation of the case um until that
investigation is completed this case has
been under investigation for at least
two years and some suggest it will be at
least that long if it if it continues
and it will continue with or without uh
general pinochet the
the
original complaint in this case was
filed by a an association or a union of
pr of prosecutors acting in their
private capacity but was not done by the
public prosecutor as would be
the only way in which a criminal case
could commence in the united states so
there was a little bit of confusion
about who what the role of prosecutors
was they did this in their private
capacity simply to lend a a weight to
the complaint as it was initially filed
since that time it's been carried
forward by these private prosecutors
pushing
uh the the investigation forward with
more or less neutrality by the public
prosecutors until just this last week in
which
at which time the public prosecutor the
the
the chief prosecutor for the national
tribunal in which judge garcon sits has
taken a more aggressive role
in attacking his jurisdiction
but most folks say that those attacks
have been fended off successfully on
much the same grounds on previous
occasions
it's a dream of every law student to ask
their professors a hypothetical
so
professor tiger and professor arnwicker
here's a hypothetical virginia governor
jim gilmore travels to south america
while in argentina he is arrested by
argentine police as the result of a
request from paraguay
assume para y as a party to a treaty
that considers capital punishment to be
a human rights violation
federal y seeks to prosecute governor
gilmore for the execution of a
paraguayan national
who was
put to death in virginia without having
the opportunity to contact his consulate
ignoring the existence or non-existence
of actual treaties is this a realistic
scenario how far does the net cast by
international human rights prosecutors
go
professor tiger
well if if there is a
first there has to be a statute in
paraguay
that makes a crime
whatever it is that this person is said
to have done
it isn't a crime to violate the
provisions of a treaty unless there's a
statute in place that says so
um
what what would we say we'd say that
paraguay would decide to make it a
some sort of crime against humanity to
participate in some meaningful way in an
execution and to fail to do something to
stop it
um
let's let's define that let's define
that problem out of existence although
paraguay in law would have to say that
he had some affirmative duty as governor
to head this off to exercise executive
clemency or whatever
which would criminalize
something approaching non-action right
then he'd have a number of procedural
defenses having to do with what the
active state doctrine or
something like that i mean he's got a
bunch of defenses but once we put all of
that aside
let's understand very clearly what's
happened here yes
there is an international law there is
international law there are norms of
international law if we take it that
executions are a violation of
fundamental principles of international
law that is to say use cogans
if we take it that paraguay chooses to
criminalize that kind of behavior
and if we take it that their
jurisdiction is based on the
execution of a paraguayan national right
so there's clearly clearly any problem
about some extra territoriality or
whatever it was directed at paraguay
national
then
governor gilmore should probably take
his vacation someplace else
one of the consequences of making and
applying rules of this kind in
recognition of principles of
international law
is that the weight of the international
community is used to isolate
sovereigns who decide to violate those
norms and to put restrictions on where
they can safely go in the world
that indeed is one of the reasons the
americans are opposed to this
international criminal court it means
that somebody other than the permanent
members of the security council are
making rules
and hey that's a fact of the world ever
since 1917
uh and particularly
in the wake of the
uh liberation of the former colonies
after the second world war
professor
i have a somewhat more conservative take
on this um
which is that i think it's important to
understand because what happened last
week sort of sent shock waves through
the international community i think it's
really important to keep in perspective
that the kind of international law that
makes it okay for spain to prosecute
crimes committed in chile
that international law applies only to a
handful of extremely atrocious crimes
international law is actually extremely
sensitive to the sensibilities of
sovereign states and it's quite rare
indeed for international law to say
spain with our blessing you may arrest a
head of state from chile and try him in
your courts under your law for what he
did
when he was head of state and basically
international law says it's okay to do
that only with respect to
the most serious crimes we can all
imagine and that is crimes against
humanity
genocide serious war crimes and then a
handful of other crimes
is it possible that international law
will continue to expand that list of
crimes sure
it's possible but i do think it's
important to keep in perspective that
what the judge did was not to reach out
and grab somebody on a frivolous charge
or even on a serious charge but on the
most serious charge and it's only in
those extreme cases that international
law permits this to happen and it might
be helpful if i can just briefly explain
the theory behind that again because i
think we need to keep in perspective
what's going on here they're really two
theories underlying universal
jurisdiction one is that some crimes are
so atrocious that they don't just defend
the individual victims and their
relatives and their community but they
offend all of us
i wish we could listen to what the
phrase crimes against humanity means in
a fresh way we're so used to it we don't
hear it anymore but it really is meant
to say humanity itself is the victim
when primes on the order of what
pinochet did
occur
so that's one idea the second idea is
that precisely when those crimes happen
on such an enormous scale
can we really expect the country where
they occurred to find some kind of
justice for the victims
in all likelihood the the citizens of
that country are in a straitjacket
politically judicially otherwise they
have to accept an amnesty
and the international community is not
in the same position they're in a
position to reach out and assist
the survivors of atrocities and to say
you may not have the resources
politically or otherwise in your country
to find justice but we're here to to
help you um and so that that's the
theory um i think the sort of parade of
porridge um scenario has been a real
concern it's understandable that that
leaders all over the world right now are
kind of nervous about where they're
going to vacation
and the reality has been that there
hasn't been this kind the kind of
frivolous or or even legitimate suit
that you've
potentially legitimates that you've
hypothesized
the reality has been that states have
been very reluctant to enforce the law
they're allowed to enforce and that's
why we're all stunned by what happened a
week ago what we're seeing is a shock to
the international system and the shock
is not that new principles are being
enforced but that old principles that
have been on our books for half a
century are being enforced that's the
reality countries aren't too eager to
enforce this law so i you know i think
those are legitimate questions i think
we have to take them very seriously but
i think it's very important right now to
keep them in
perspective when i pose a question
professor because i didn't think there's
a universal jurisdiction question in the
hypothetical paraguay wants to try
somebody for killing a paraglian
i mean that's
but they want to try
they want to try them for prosecution
for doing something in the united states
um the point there is that the principle
of passive nationality the fact that you
can try someone because
he or she had the nationality of your
country is a very highly debatable issue
so that's why diana is trying to find a
universal basis for jurisdiction i i
think that your question is very
important
because it touches on
very serious issues as a matter of fact
the the the first one is the way in
which we develop international law we do
not develop international law in a
systematic fashion with the centralized
congress that
takes into account if that type of
congress would exist as a matter of fact
every element and then decides in a
syllogistic way what will happen and
that international law does not develop
in that way develop characteristically i
mean we saw the
nuremberg
cases for example it was the first
the time that that happened in many ways
then
we continued again with the
tribunal and the crimes in former
yugoslavia then rwanda then we saw the
eichmann case and then we saw the
nordiga case now
i do think away and i hope that this
type of cases will go into a direction
of a court of values
the code of criminal offences against
humankind and that could be
adjudicated in a central way because
there are serious issues with domestic
education of international norms on the
basis of the principle of universal
jurisdiction for example
we want and that's the aspiration we
have in the legal system that for the
same crime people get the same penalty
and the courts in paraguay for example
could have a different decision that the
courts in sweden or in argentina
why that that does not has not happened
it could happen in the future and i
think that we should cease the momentum
also to push
for the development of fundamental
values of human dignity and a code of
value that is translated in an
international criminal tribunal with a
coherent jurisprudence
otherwise
there are certainly dangers there is
another issue
this type of criticism could be
theoretically valid
but we should avoid the following
temptation saying that because there is
a chance of free or lost litigation when
we have an opportunity to do justice we
let that opportunity go because of the
hypothetical what we can say is the
following we're going to cease in the
hypothetical to build on that more than
to
question the whole process because of
the uncertainties that this creates from
the point of view of world order
professor wilson
um
if you could please comment on some of
the some of the issues that have been
going on in chile right now that have
been affecting them domestically for
example chilean politicians have
received threats against their lives
former members of the now disbanded dina
and cni secret police forces have
regrouped to discuss the arrest of their
former commander-in-chief
right-wing mayors of two sectors within
santiago have suspended garbage
collection
and refused additional police protection
for both the spanish and british
embassies
rallies both pro pinochet and auntie
pinochet have disrupted the city
right-wing members of the chilean
congress staged a walkout which was
criticized by president eduardo frey
the question in light of chile's
fledgling democracy is this eruption
disruption of the chilean political
scene
too high a price to pay
well
i think
as a if we look historically at what has
happened in chile and
claudio's followed the situation
as closely as anyone
so i would invite his comments as well
but
they certainly survived
the trial
conviction and incarceration of the two
highest ranking members
of the secret police there who were
involved in the killing of orlando
l'italia here
in the united states and at the time
that those
trials were going forward at the time
that the generals
surrendered there were rumblings and
activities quite similar to the kind
that are now taking place now
we're watching quite closely so you have
every detail of the what the
international press is is looking at to
to stir the pot
ultimately those two
individuals those two members of the
secret police surrendered and are now
serving their time in prison
and general pinochet despite the fact
that he had threatened
disruption of a military nature if one
hair on the head of any of his people
was touched
was
forced into silence
essentially
put to the sidelines
we have complained
uh historically about
the difficulty of
prosecuting only those who are in the
lower ranks or the middle ranks
of the wrongdoers we never go for the
big fish
we are going for the big fish
and
when you do that
you
are
talking about bringing down
i think an apparatus as well as an
individual
and
i think there is a
a way in which
this case because it has such moral
force because it has legal force behind
it it is not a frivolous undertaking has
that kind of power to silence uh
opposition
when and if
this trial
goes forward so i'm i'm actually quite
optimistic that the that the country can
survive dean grossman
i think that chile is facing a serious
situation as a matter of fact the
general penance was
seen as a symbol
by
an important segment of the population
one of the things that you could see
there is a different imperception
between a sector that supports the you
know you know pinochet
and the perception that many have
outside chile concerning a general
piracy and
and there is like a shock to see this
type of world reaction they they they
had seen the generally negative
enlightened
and there are serious issues facing
chile i i
i would say that the some of the reasons
for these serious issues is that like in
personal relations
truth and reality need to be seen in the
eye it's not possible to swept under the
rag important historical events we have
seen what happened in former yugoslavia
for example and in other situations
where issues are not handled in a
positive way i'm not talking here not
having a pragmatic
approach to issues of politics i think
that there is a need of a combination
for idealism and pragmatism in every
political situation but
the fact that it has not been possible
for example to find the
more than the thousand disappeared
persons in chile i mean there is this
sense of frustration creates a
tremendous tension in the society and it
surfaces in many ways it could now it
was in an action in the uk and spain it
would have been in another way now
i would like to say however they follow
i think that there is a tremendous
degree of consensus in chilean politics
today in many ways there is consensus as
to the value of democracy not as an
instrument of politics but
as a value of democracy itself as a way
of life and i think that's important
there is also tremendous consensus in
chile concerning the role of the private
sector in economics and in the in the
economy
in the country there is a range
of views
involving the the value of solidarity
taxation what happened with the weak and
the poor but i think
that there are enough bases there
to continue to build now
i uh history is done by people and and
it depends on what what will happen in
chile and how many actors will react
i've seen the government calling for
khan and
i've seen many actors trying not to add
the you know to a polarization this
major of
santiago
of one of the cities surrounding
santiago uh was criticized even by the
right-wing parties right this important
instrument in politics they're entitled
to have their opinion they haven't
they're entitled to have their opinions
on pinac as well
but the criticism that was a exercise on
him and resulted in a suspension of of
this type of irritating kind i do think
aware that there is a serious situation
and that calls for statementship and
for people trying to put in the center
the things that unite more than divide
and
and i think that we need to remain
vigilant because there is a serious
situation of course there
professor tiger professor wilson had
brought up the uh orlando l'italiere
bombing and that uh generals contreras
and espinosa are now in prison serving
sentences in
in chile right now could you comment a
little bit on the on the uh the case on
the uh l'italia case uh leave it kind of
as an open-ended sort of direction
anyway you'd like to take that as your
experience with trying to prosecute
these or as trying to bring these types
of uh
crimes to to
justice well yeah
of course we didn't have any question of
of
uh competence of an american tribunal
the killings took place in the united
states so the chileans attempted to
raise defenses including act of state
and discretionary act under a sort of
cognate to the federal tort claims act
once we had a judgment uh which we got
against the republic of chile and
against the individuals then the
question was of enforcing it at the
point where
uh samba phone had succeeded in getting
some legislation proposed to amend the
foreign sovereign immunities act to give
us more targets to go after we couldn't
seize law chile airplanes we tried and
couldn't get it collected
then then president hale when president
bush agreed to setting up an
international tribunal and eventually we
collected
uh the equivalent of the judgment
um
that's the case
now then in the meantime however we ask
ourselves well what you know is there
any chance of bringing pinochet to
justice in chile
no that's a practical matter that
the
laws are doing that in chile are pretty
slim
so the choices the choice the family has
is now to go and join
the effort to support the instructional
process in spain in the hopes there'll
be criminal charges brought there
why
because
as professor arndt liker points out
there are a few crimes that are
punishable as a matter of so-called
universal jurisdiction that's not a hard
concept uh pirates if you caught a
pirate in the 17th century 18th century
you bring them wherever you caught them
you bring them to triumph why there was
because piracy was regarded as that kind
of a crime a crime against everybody and
against everything
um the real fight now is that the
evidence
how is it that president pinochet could
feel that with impunity you could kill
people in the united states
well
because there were a lot of foreign
secret services operating in the united
states and killing people and rounding
them up and disrupting their meetings
and hey what's one more we can play too
that was what the church committee found
uh and we saw everybody read the new
york times this morning the op art
the united states government is not
cooperating with the spanish authorities
they are taking we're here we'll have
your files and then you get top page
this is about pinichet and all the rest
of the page is blacked out and that's
called cooperation
um
we knew that two days after orlando
latalia and ronnie moffatt were killed i
met with then attorney general levy and
he said listen george bush is not going
to cooperate with this he was then
director of the cia
and
that was the story we'll eventually got
some cooperation from the cia the demand
now has to be that the american
authorities must respect the ch the
spanish
judicial process
and if they do not
then the participation of the lately or
moffat families as parties in spain
means that in our view they have
standing
before a court of the united states to
compel that form of cooperation
and sam before and i can you know go
back to court and do something about it
um
because that's that's the really
shameful part
the we could have prosecuted and we
won't we have a duty if we're not going
to do that to support the effort in
spain
it's not going to be good
um i want to add that i really agree
wholeheartedly with
everything michael tiger just said i'd
like to add that i consider it really
regrettable that the united states
government has not even verbally
supported these prosecutions and has
been conspicuously neutral about them
despite the fact that an american
citizen
was killed along with um orlando
latelier in the heart of washington and
despite the fact that this
administration is in theory committed to
um justice for um for crimes of disorder
and and if i could i know you're anxious
to move on to the next question but i
just wanted to add very briefly um
more of an underlying too something that
rick wilson said a few minutes ago about
the lately or moffatt case because i
think it's very pertinent to the issue
claudio just addressed and i think it's
the most important issue here and that
is
will these prosecutions if they're
pursued
have
a deleterious effect on the fragile
process of moving toward democracy in
chile and i think that's the single most
important issue and when we should as
claudio admonished us take very
seriously um when the
the l'italia mafia case was explicitly
exempted from the chilean amnesty law of
1978. um there was a lot of writing on
that exemption at the united states
congress and i'm sure this was a result
of the efforts of uh mr tiger and mr
buffon but the united states congress
was holding up military i'm sorry usa to
chile until there was progress in that
case
despite that despite all of the pressure
and it was pretty significant pressure
coming from washington over a long
period
for there to be justice in that case and
despite the fact that legally it was
exempt from the amnesty law
advisers to the successor government of
pinochet privately told michael moffatt
in my presence it's not going to happen
politically it can't happen it will be
too divisive
that that you know we know now that that
didn't happen and we also know as
professor wilson noted that it was
divisive it was actually provocative to
prosecute these people the military
didn't appreciate it nonetheless they
stayed in their barracks that the
government survived that confrontation
and most importantly it was strengthened
for having met the military on this
issue faced it down
and i think that strengthened democracy
so the two points i want to make is that
we should take these issues seriously
there it this isn't light stuff this is
really serious stuff but secondly i
think there can be a very important part
on the role on the part of outsiders
bystanders states in creating more space
than there otherwise would have been
for chileans to
secure some measure of justice
well i've monopolized the time up here
enough what i'd like to do now is open
it up to
your questions uh from the audience we
have a microphone set up right here if
you could move towards the microphone if
you have any any questions
while you're doing that i'll go ahead
and throw out one more but please just
start
moving over this way if you do have
questions that you'd like to ask the
panel
while you're doing that
i've just thought this out to professor
wilson um
the the question's been brought up
professor wilson what moral authority do
the spanish have to prosecute pinochet
in light of the colonial exploitation of
latin america and the more recent regime
of francisco franco
they're
in some senses
no no country
is uh without sin
there is a
a very real
a sense in which
that is the reason why
countries do this so rarely
uh because there is not that political
will to to act against a neighbor for
fear that retaliation will be taken
against one's
one's own country
uh i think in fact the conditions of
post-franco spain
made it a good deal more difficult
for
opposition
to appear in the in the relatively
conservative government of spain for
fear of sounding as though they were
supportive of pinochet
and they were trying to put distance
between themselves and the prior
dictatorship in
in spain
so their the political conditions i
think were absolutely the right
conditions for this kind of prosecution
particularly given the courage
of judge garcon who now has both of the
cases under his jurisdiction
this is a judge who i have seen
characterized
in the press as relatively left-wing
when in fact
he is he has given credit inside of
spain
for having
contributed to the downfall of the uh
government of felipe gonzalez socialist
government of felipe gonzalez as a
result of their involvement in
clandestine support for
paramilitary units that took on the
basques separatist
eta
in the north of the country
over a period of time so
he is not
a political person he is responding i
think out of a a deep sense of
legality and morality which i think is
the highest kind of aspiration we could
look for in any independent judge to
take this kind of action forward it is
it is uh it is that that this case is
about
you know if you're interested in that
theory you know jacques valjean who
represented klaus bobby attempted that
defense
you know how can you prosecute klaus
bobby the butcher of lyon
because after all the atrocities
committed by the french in algeria
and um that got a big ho-hum i mean it
didn't even work at a political level
and and certainly we all know what
happened in the case so
um if for those of you that are thinking
of running that defense um
really it doesn't
it it didn't work for klaus barbie and i
don't recommend it
so
thank you
um step right up
um before i ask i just want to correct
the moderator
palestinian territory is occupied by
israel and not israeli occupied
territories thank you
for my question
um
was there any role for american
foreign policy in bringing minorities to
power cia
and if there was should there anyone be
brought to
uh
justice if not criminal justice than
public justice
i think there's little doubt i think the
uh ambassador to chile at the time of
the fall of the nda government has
himself written a book about
the role that the cia played and
certainly as a matter of us foreign
policy in the fall of
of
allende
and
that role i think was quite extensive i
think there is a
on the same page with
an article recently on
the spanish prosecution was this the
rather matter-of-fact statement that the
cia admitted it knew
of um
activities that had been undertaken by
the honduran um
secret police and had been aware of
their activities that were outside of
the law
the question of the relationship between
uh
that that kind of activity that is
activity which is undertaken in the
intelligence community
and how that may lead to
state responsibility i think is is an
even more complex question i think it
were a long way from having
been close to being able to resolve the
question of what
what level of responsibility
a government
has when it engages in covert activity
that may be
necessary as it perceives for the
survival of its own its own nation
the national security archives has
obtained the release of all great many
records that show direct american
involvement in the overthrow of the andy
government and uh a role of applauding
the uh
brutality with which the coup was
carried out so i don't think there's any
doubt about that
then the question is well you know what
what do you do about it
um
the um
for right now
um i guess we don't do
anything
about the fact that our government has
repeatedly been involved in activities
of that kind
uh that
i think as professor wilson points out
it's it's a little hard to point to some
specific offense under
uh
under international law
uh that is of a criminal nature although
the direct interference in the internal
affairs of chile
certainly raises international law
questions that could be brought before
the icj in some form or another it's
hard to think of a lawsuit but nicaragua
tried it and we saw where that got i
think it got a long ways in terms of
international public opinion
what do we do about that i'll just take
a minute
the question of prosecutorial discretion
that is being raised you know why are
the spaniards doing this
is raised every time there are criminal
offenses
federal prosecutors have time to
prosecute one percent of all the crimes
going on in america and a miniscule
maybe eight or five or ten percent of
all the crimes that are suffered with a
federal criminal code what do they do
they use prosecutorial discretion do we
like how they do it me no i don't
uh what do i do about it well we try to
influence the exercise of that
discretion that's the process we're
talking about now
ultimately we've got to do in our
country what the south africans did in
their country we've got to take power
and when we take power and change things
then we can decide should we prosecute
everybody or should we have a truth and
reconciliation commission to try to find
out all that went on so that it doesn't
happen again
we as lawyers are in charge of
remembering we're in charge of
remembering so that the bad things don't
happen anymore and we have a lot of
tools available to us to try to stop
them from happening of which the
invocation of criminal law is only one
your
opening remark about
uh the israelis occupying palestine land
in violation of international law
you know and
how do we solve that well there are a
whole number of ways of which the
potential invocation of international
criminal law is just one and a very
small one at that
hi my name is juan carlo benavides i'm a
chilean national living washington
my main concern had to do with
in your opinion do you think that the
spanish justice system is independent
enough from the government or from any
other
institution where there
to give the green light for the
traditional process to england
because otherwise maybe that's going to
be the end of this
enterprise this week if any answer to
that
i i read in the paper this morning and
i'm following it each day that uh the uh
the prime minister of
both of both countries had said that
they were going to stand aside that this
was a legal proceeding and that the
government's
the central governments were not going
to intervene we've seen a lot in the
papers about
the necessity of this
extradition request going up through the
high levels of government central
government and then back
through this a similarly high level on
the other
side of the channel i think
there is an effort though by those
individuals to stand aside and that was
how this case began as an as an
extradition it began as a legal matter
not as a political matter and i think
that's that's where they stand right now
but isn't the case that there is
something like a supreme court uh judges
that are supposed to decide this week
about the whole thing yes the difficulty
you raise a difficulty
and the difficulty is that the judicial
establishments of countries on the
continent of europe tend to be
relatively conservative
even in
and and we saw that and i can't predict
what's going to happen here but you saw
that in klaus barbie's case
you remember in klaus barbie's case the
the cul de cacion required that they
that it be proved at his trial that he
acted not simply as we would understand
the crime against humanity but in the
service of a power that sought to
establish hegemony on racial grounds
they defined it so narrowly that they
had to prove he was an actual agent of
the nazi regime now the impact of that
was to make it much more difficult to go
after people like duvier who never wore
a nazi uniform
you know killed all the jews he possibly
could manage to kill and did so in the
interest of the vichy government but
after all they were french weren't they
um well they they got to va
but it wasn't for want of a relatively
conservative judiciary attempting to
narrow the definition of a crime against
humanity so i think that you have you
know you've raised a problem because
they're going to be issues of double
incrimination
they're going to be into questions
therefore of interpretation of these
laws and that's going to be something
for lawyers to to watch and even with
the
you know the political branch of
government saying oh let the judges
decide it um
you know i i've got nine stories to tell
you about what goes on down on capitol
hill if you need to hear that so um this
is not a process free from the political
you know ideology i think
hi i'd like to direct this question to
anyone who can answer it
why do you think the judge chose
to charge pinochet with genocide as
opposed to crimes against humanity
given
my understanding that that's a more
difficult charge and also how do you
think such a charge would be applied to
this case can i say a word about that
and then i'm going to
bounce the question to rick who can
elaborate um
as rick will explain
with greater erie edition than i can
the charge of genocide exists in spanish
in the spanish penal code the charge of
crimes against humanity those words
don't
but my understanding and i'm going to
let rick correct me if i'm wrong about
this is that under spanish law genocide
is interpreted more broadly than it is
under international law now that is
perfectly permissible states may always
in domestic law apply a broader
definition but what is important and i
really want to emphasize this
my understanding of the way it might be
interpreted under spanish law that is
the charge of genocide is that
um the way it's interpreted in spanish
law corresponds to the way crimes
against humanity are defined in
international law
therefore it is perfectly proper for
spain to apply its law to what happened
in chile under international law we
would call these crimes against humanity
the word they use in spanish law is
genocide
rick do you want to clarify elaborate
well i think there are a couple of uh a
couple of twists to this i think that's
a very good question the
the
a lot of folks have asked about the
the genesis of the uh of a genocide
charge here as a central component to
this the
spanish law actually had a provision
from 1971
to 1983
a crucial period here we're talking
about
uh that that included the word social
group
in its statute which is a different
definition
than the conventions definition of
genocide that in itself is a recognition
as professor erin looker says of
the domestic differences that the way in
which spanish domestic law defines as
well it can
the crime of genocide within spain
uh
as opposed to the the convention's
definition
and the judge himself has suggested in
defending his jurisdiction this is judge
garcon
that it is appropriate to refer to
the victims
as members of a social group during that
period of time he also however has used
a
a theory on nationality
and religious grounds which is similarly
persuasive and similarly based both on
his interpretation
of what constitutes a vision
of a national
unity that was held by
the generals in argentina that he he
ruled in the argentine context so we we
we're drawing we're using parallels now
to that for the chilean context when he
was attacked
jurisdictionally in the argentine cases
that the that the vision of the military
was
i believe the term they used was the
process of national reorganization
that's the formal term that they used uh
to
catch up
any
their their enterprise and see any
opponent
political or otherwise
in very much the same way that the nazis
saw their opponents as opposed to a view
of vision
of a nation that holds particular
characteristics which those people do
not so there's a way in which
nationality describes what this
enterprise was about he also does the
same with religion with regard to
religious characteristics
i think that this is probably the point
that is going to be debated the most the
convention against genocide does not
include the political groups as a matter
of fact and
and there are here seriously
real issues
particularly in light of the following
is the irrespective of what the
spanish law says if we try and find a
universal foundation or the
international foundation is very
important to refer back to international
norms
and
in terms of the convention against
genocide
on the one hand and in the second hand
the fact that to establish penal
responsibility then they need to have a
penalty type that describes the behavior
and gives
then advanced notice on the basis of a
universal foundation is very important
so i think that this probably ground is
the ground that
will give rise to a lot of debates i i
think that myself that
probably
the judge is on a better grounds when
he's talking about the international
terrorism yes
again this is uh
this is
the i i think that you all know that the
basis of the investigation of the judge
is
something called operation condor which
was the extermination
on the basis of a coordination by the
dictatorial regimes in the southern cone
of latin america and that included
actions in argentina uruguay and other
countries and
and some
of these actions were of course the act
of
terrorism as a matter of fact and then
we have the move ahead in terms of the
idea and that is rest now in more solid
grounds that there is universal
jurisdiction there i am not against as a
matter of fact expansion of concepts but
i have to say
that the convention does not typify the
political crime of genus
the principle of nuremberg did talk
about the extermination of political
groups but not the convention and in
terms of penal responsibilities i think
that there are issues there that need
really to be explored better
i would remind that pinochet purported
to strip orlando lately of his
citizenship
in pursuit of this ideal
i mean you're against us you're not a
chilean and uh milan orlando rejected
the invitation not to be at chilean but
uh during his lifetime but that was that
that was the idea of hegemony that was
the meaning of this national
reorganization
in closing uh our own dean jeffy
suggested a final question
to each of the panelists where do you
think this is going
are we standing on the brink of a new
international attitude towards
international human rights
or is this merely
yet another flavor of the month
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
that's shakespeare
well
um
i don't think it i don't know and i
don't think it matters
in the summer before nelson mandela was
released from prison i stood on a
hilltop for hillside in cape town and we
were training lawyers to
try cases involving the massive
demonstrations that summer by the mass
democratic movement which had not yet
been banned
and a year later mandela was released
and because they did bring the
government effectively to a halt and
demonstrated their power and alby sachs
who's now in the constitutional court of
south africa who had been a banned
person we couldn't say his name in
public and if you had a book by him you
could be arrested
um and people were being tried for that
said well
all revolutions are inevitable until
they happen or else if all revolutions
are impossible until they happen then
they become inevitable
you see
um
in a dialectical process which is why i
think history works we never know
just what it is
that's going to provoke
the fundamental change and mean that
this time this step towards progress
signals something all we can do
is do the next right thing without fear
that in doing it we're going to start
something that's terrible and and
dangerous and so on
so
i think that there's great promise that
this step forward towards
making these norms mean something
is going to be a positive one
but if it doesn't play out this time
there are enough such steps in which
everybody in this room can participate
and should participate and will i think
participate that um it doesn't matter
we'll get them next time
i i don't know if i can miss it more
eloquently than that it seems that
i i'm i i think that uh
there are
certainly days in in which uh i feel
frustrated i think there are
uh
there are days when those who are
engaged in this fight put themselves at
great physical risk alby sacks lost an
arm
many lawyers engage in the kind of
activity that we engage in here
as criminal defense lawyers as human
rights lawyers
and put themselves at physical risk of
detention
torture death
every day that they practice law most of
us don't have to face
that kind of test of our moral
commitment to a goal of justice
it seems to me if if if one
tries to think about what animates those
lawyers to take the steps that they take
it is a commitment to that idea of
justice and i i owed a peter chiquino
one of our fellow faculty his when we
were discussing this the other day his
invocation of an old latin phrase that
says do justice
and let the heavens fall
thank you for the latin
um i i wanted to see two things first
the first thing i want to say is in some
respects an answer to the very first
question you asked i've been struck
looking out at the audience that how
much this event has spanned a generation
as you probably gathered from everything
we've said
a lot of us have been um
at this for a long time and in many ways
the country of chile and its own
very dramatic effort to confront
it's it's past
has been
has had a galvanizing effect on the
global human rights movement and it's
been such a long time coming and i have
to say it's such an honor to be sitting
next to michael tiger in the same room
as sam buffon whom i met
22 years ago when i was a law student
and concerned about the lately or
moffett case and i know how long they've
been at it and i know what a herculean
task it has seemed and it's amazing to
me to look at the audience and see
people who were my age 22 years ago
and know that this is still a concern
but that we have this phenomenal
phenomenal phenomenal step forward and
so my answer to the question that david
asked which is an excellent question is
that however this ends i mean almost
however this ends a giant step has been
taken in the global human rights
movement
whatever comes next if pinochet is
released on a technicality if he's
released because he's sick
something absolutely extraordinary has
happened and we really ought to sort of
take a deep breath and and be in awe of
this
individuals who had more courage than
political leaders in the past two
decades
were able to say you know the legal
equivalent of this emperor has no close
they were able to say even pinochet
is not entirely above the law and
a very courageous judge with an
incredible integrity
was able to stop
this flow of impunity and to say
general pinochet
must be detained
on the order of the law not on a whim
not on a caprice not on an arbitrary
action but on order of the law the rule
of law and um it's really an
extraordinary moment and i i know you
all appreciate that but whatever happens
next uh this has been a great great step
forward
i i believe that the actions taken by
the
justice in the uk and the actions by the
spanish judges open up possibilities
in from the point of view of
international law in terms of
establishing
and reaffirming the value of individual
responsibility
and for for crimes against humanity and
for terrorism for torture
for
a long time
leaders have hide behind the
government and
they have said
we are not guilty here and the state is
responsible and has been a way to spread
the blame and the guilt on everyone and
the fact that the humankind is moving
towards
a world where we can identify
responsibility and adjudicate
responsibility is essential
and justice is about that it's
about solving a concrete issue and
establishing would be what and being
fair and being just and irrespective of
the tremendous impact in terms of the
societal movements and
theoretical issues to give satisfaction
to an issue remain at the core of of
education and legal system
i also think that if we take a broader
view of this situation
the situation opens also a possibility
to goes against impunity overall
the uh
the victims they
don't want the revenge
they are not looking to the past
they want to build a future of human
dignity
and they they i thank her and i work
in the in cases in the hemisphere the
victims are not motivated by revenge
they're ready to
forgive people
if somebody asked them
and recognize that something went wrong
and
shows a repentance
what motivates the
family of manfred
velasquez the first disappeared
internationally disappeared person in
this hemisphere was justice not revenge
and i think that
and i see with the the generosity of
human beings and what they want is a
future where the children we will not
have to suffer in the same way which
they did
and and i think then that
again in this case open up possibilities
to
to live in the type of world where we
would like our children to live
one thing i would like
to adhere and this is your role and i
think that this question the question
what will happen in the future is a
question that everyone should answer and
particularly law students
you have chosen a unique and exciting
profession there is hardly an issue in
society that does not have a legal
connotation
and you can see in the most important
and reliant issues of our time you have
something to say
we have changed international reality
and the world has changed dramatically
to a situation where states are not any
longer the only actors individuals can
operate at the international plane
individuals can be the source of
treaties
the ideas and the power and force of
values are important and depend on you
so i think that the question is a
question that
which should be answered by by all of us
this open possibility but the
possibilities depend on all of you thank
you very much
well in conclusion i'd like to thank you
all for coming like to thank c-span for
coming as well everybody go home set
your vcrs and call your parents have a
good evening
cameras
[Music]
um
in a minute former president jimmy
carter